notre confrère notre confrère jean-paul
kauffmann qui vient d'être libéré à 43
ans il a été pris en otage le 22 mai
1985 je vous rappelle que jean paul
kauffmann et est envoyé comme grand
reporter au liban pour l'événement du
jeudi son enlèvement avait été
revendiqué dès le 29 mai 85 par le
djihad islamique 22 mai 1985 c'est sur
la route de l'aéroport de beyrouth en
plein combat entre chiites et
palestiniens ce que jean paul kauffmann
michel seurat sont enlevés dix jours
plus tard revendications du jihad
islamique
il réclame la libération des 17
terroristes prisonniers au koweït pour
relâcher le chercheur michel seurat et
le journaliste jean paul kauffmann les
amis de jean paul kauffmann décide de
porter la faire sur la place publique
ils organisent les manifestations
auxquelles sont associées les diplomates
marcel carton et marcel fontaine enlevé
deux mois plus tôt le comité kaufmann
reçoit des lettres par milliers organise
des expositions de dessins d'enfants sur
le thème de la liberté et multiplie les
interventions
joëlle kauffmann choisi la stratégie de
l'action 12 juin dans un beyrouth chaque
jour plus déchiré
joëlle kauffmann tente d'arracher
quelques informations aux dignitaires
religieux des quartiers chics le djihad
réclament maintenant la libération du
commando qui a tenté d'assassiner
chapour bakhtiar l'ancien premier
ministre iranien
à cette époque le mot clé de la
situation paraît être nabih berry le
chef du groupe amal l'homme qui a fait
libérer les passagers de la twh et pour
les otages français
c'est la puissance 13 mars 1986 l'équipe
d'antenne 2 vient d'être enlevé michel
sera peut-être assassiné des milliers de
personnes écoutent avec émotion l'appel
de joëlle kauffmann savez ce que vous
venez de faire mieux que vous
discréditer et d'idées votre cause aux
yeux du peuple français de tout vos amis
je vous en supplie
22 mai une manifestation de plus
silencieuse
cela fait exactement un an jean paul
kauffmann a été enlevé le 21 juin
joëlle kauffmann bouleversé assiste à
l'arrivée à paris de philippe rochot et
jan janssen libéré maintenant travailler
plus des trois mois après le djihad
islamique envoie une cassette du jean
paul kauffmann amaigri mais la voix
ferme nous sommes pas dutil des intérêts
supérieurs aux 87 dernier message de
jean paul kauffmann et pire serait ce
que l'on sait pour lui ce que l'on en
sait plus depuis une dizaine de minutes
sur le mécanisme de la libération des
trois derniers otages français non non
pas vraiment parce que monsieur pasqua
elle ne veut pas parler est ce qu'on
s'est simplement est ce qu'on peut
imaginer en tout cas c'est que les
tractations vous vire ont duré trois ans
et que n'ont jamais cessé en fait est
que finalement il y a eu des tractations
au niveau des états parce qu'on dit
qu'on traite avec des étapes au niveau
du terrain parce qu'il faut traiter les
gens qui détiennent les otages alors les
tractations sont terriblement l'épée
bande ce qu'on avait à l'iran les
paiements ce qu'on doit aussi aux
ravisseurs parce qu'on leur doit quelque
chose c'est de jouer un jour une
bakchich autre chose mais c'est comme ça
vous savez quand aussi un marché en
orient il faut aussi payer sous la table
c'est comme ça tout le monde le sait et
finalement on se ne fut-ce que pas quand
il s'agit de la liberté des hommes
compétents faire autant il ya toujours
quinze otages dont un américain ont
reconnu ban il faut être aussi avoir une
pensée pour le chercheur michel sorin
d'abord il ya toujours quinze otages
avec d'autres pays qui prétendent ne pas
ne pas pratiquer les mêmes voies que
nous pour arriver à la libération de
leurs ressortissants c'est leur problème
c'est leur affaire mais il faut être
solidaire solidaire en tout cas des
otages et puis en même temps il faut
avoir une pensée pour michel seurat
c'est vrai j'étais à beyrouth quand on a
annoncé sa mort quand on a montré ses
photos
personne n'ya cru vraiment parce qu'on a
analysées autour d'iso n'est pas
vraiment mort on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas très bien on a jamais vu ce qui
s'est passé on ne sait pas
malheureusement il n'est plus là
l'avez-vous unis comme tous les
journalistes de la rédaction d'antenne
de ce soir vous êtes mobilisés vous êtes
pendu au téléphone et je crois que vous
êtes en mesure de nous révéler que
l'algérie a joué un rôle primordial dans
la libération des otages français
effectivement il algérie ont eu un rôle
déterminant dans cette libération
elle n'a d'ailleurs jamais été absente
des négociations pour obtenir un heureux
dénouement
on se souvient des remerciements
adressés à l'algérie par le premier
ministre jacques chirac au moins la
libération une équipe d'antenne 2 et de
roger auque jamais absente l'algérie
donc dans un intérêt strictement
humanitaires insistons là bas et par
delà tous les clivages politiques
insistent temps précise intérêts
humanitaire vous en souvenez henry ce
sont les mots utilisés par edith edery
le ministre de l'intérieur algérien au
moment du détournement du bowling
koweïtien il ya quinze jours une affaire
en étroite relation avec nos otages
les auteurs de ce détournement on le
sait appartiennent à la même mouvance
que ceux qui détenaient carton fontaine
et kaufman cette fois encore l'algérie a
donc garantie que tout se passerait
comme prévu ce rôle de garant a été
sollicité au plus haut niveau des
parties concernées à paris très tôt dans
la nuit
la machine était enclenché deux moments
précis était prévue pour cette
libération
19h ou 2 heures du matin et c'est bien
vers 19 heures qu'une mercedes est
apparue là-bas à beyrouth avec à son
bord nos otages
merci je vous donne les principales
réactions qui viennent de nous parvenir